well let's talk about what the next step
is because my friends if you thought
Elon Musk was going to save you I'm
sorry
we may have won a battle
I tell you this moment is like the
battle for Helm's Deep and we made one
last ride and then up in the in the
break of dawn we saw Elon Musk the white
wizard coming to our rescue but the war
is not over we still have to get the One
Ring of censorship to Mount Doom and
what's happening now is the bite
Administration is calling for Section
230 reform Obama has called for more
regulations on speech you've got Ed
Markey calling for uh algorithmic
justice he called it
lawmakers are calling for greater
oversight of social media according to
the White House Biden has long argued
that Tech platforms must be held
accountable when they lose in the
private sector where they've controlled
the narrative for so long they are
falling back to the public sector and
they're going to try to use government
as their cudgel to beat people down and
maintain that narrative so battle may be
won
but we must get the ring of censorship
to Mount Doom yeah so when Biden says
they need to be held accountable for the
harms they cause do you think he might
be referring to the fact that they
suppressed a true story about his son
which in part contributed to him being
elected as president of the United
States well they're losing that power
Elon Musk publicly comes out and says
they should not have done that and Joe
Biden's like oh geez man how am I going
to win he's like 24. come on
come on come on man I can't win an
election without a Tech censoring people
and and shutting down conversations
around what my kid does AFT Time
Magazine I can't I can't what am I going
to do what's their oversight that they
want to create there it's it's nebulous
but they're like we can't allow
disinformation I don't think they'll win
well but they've already I mean they've
already started doing this remember they
were telling large social media
platforms that they had to censor
certain information surrounding kova 19.
and they did yeah and we saw that uh
what wasn't like media companies getting
uh subsidy on like vaccine issues or
something like that absolutely right
when when uh what did we see the
Democratic party went to Twitter I think
it was saying certain people should be
banned and it was a weird Tom fit and
just the other day who was talking about
that so I right right there was some
kind of expose they did where the
Democrats were actually sending messages
like hey get rid of these people the
coordination between the White House and
the tech media companies it's been I
think eye-opening and it's scary and the
collaboration and and the coordination
between the two is what McCarthy should
investigate if they get the majority and
they're going to need subpoenas and
they're going to need preservation of
record requests and those should go out
now
and it's going to be very hard even if
you have an aggressive Republican
leadership in the House of
Representatives to get after this
because you're going to face resistance
delays stalling tactics from the
administration and the White House the
executive privilege issues all of that
and they'll try to run out the clock but
they have to go after it you have to
begin the fight and just like with
putting up your billboard Tim you have
to fight you have to let them know
there's going to be a cost you have to
give an example to others
our base needs it okay people need the
example to stand up and fight and go to
meetings and participate in the
democracy and they need to see their
leaders standing up I don't think Kevin
McCarthy's gonna going to do anything
I don't disagree with it
right over here well I
There's Hope but there's also hope that
one could get a different leader that's
what we need we need a speaker Trump
Maybe like more than gonna vote for I
have the greatest speaker I'd like to
ask you something so I'm really curious
about how new this relationship between
the White House and these large social
media companies is was there any inkling
when you were in the White House that
things like this had been occurring
under the Obama Administration prior to
Trump taking power absolutely right Ben
Rhodes talked about how foolish the
major mainstream media is and the tech
leadership he had that he could
manipulate them and he made fun of them
in private it came out and he was
embarrassed by that but the key issue is
that he was facilitating and
coordinating this with daily
messaging for coordinating the White
House messages and the cnns and the
msnbcs but also the social media lapped
it up
so we had that beginning in the Obama
administrator I'd say previously you
also had but wasn't as coordinated or as
effective as we saw with you know the
Advent of social media really growing
during the Obama years I mean it's
12 years ago 14 years ago now right so
things have moved along quite quickly I
I think we've got real problems here and
I think you know we're going to have to
begin the turn the turn is
possible but it's going to take
aggressive oversight it's probably going
to take another executive
leader like a trump or a DeSantis or
someone to come in and put some teeth in
doj and sec in the Federal
Communications Administration to get
after this in a way that will level the
playing field
you got to change the culture in these
industries and that comes with the green
I think
don't drain the swamp
yeah yes but you look at what happens to
Robbie Starbuck did you hear about what
happened to him in Tennessee no they
kicked him off the primary the
Republican party did they said he wasn't
a real Republican it's the dude who's
more Republic like one of the most
Republican Republicans there is that
should be challenged in court because I
think it's violating
a number of laws I mean constitutional
requirements here to drop someone off
running in in the primary candidate
primary race there in Tennessee I read
something about it I don't remember
exactly what the story was but I it
appeared that it's an overreach by the
Republican party there but it's the
establishment it's the establishment
going after the base of the party yep if
we're going to actually see any changes
in November if the Republic's going to
win there has to be a wave of populist
American first type America first type
Republicans who win but if the
Republican Party itself is rejecting
these candidates and trying to keep them
out then
why would I bother voting for a
republican well we have a lot of wins
you know we've seen that in Michigan and
other places okay and it looks like it's
going to be good in Georgia and it's
going to be good in North Carolina and I
think we're not in too bad a place in
places like Texas
um I I actually I think
maybe it would be fair for me to say
that until the Republican Party itself
the national level comes down on
Tennessee with with an iron fist weeding
out the corruption and condemning the
actions in booting Robbie Starbuck off
we should Advocate that everyone tells
the Republican party to go screw
themselves I'm not going to vote I'm not
voting for Republicans until they make
that move and restore Robbie Starbuck
because I don't want I'm not going to be
party to corruption if they want to play
stupid pathetic dirty games if the
Republicans of West Virginia of Maryland
of at the national level will not come
out and condemn this I'll tell you this
if they condemn it I'm good well in
Maryland in Maryland right here where
we're at the state Republican party is
trying to pressure County
Committees of the Republican party to
not support Dan Cox in the governor's
race
okay that's Governor Hogan okay trying
to stack the deck in favor of his chosen
successor against a real conservative
who's been endorsed by President Trump
so so uh
well elaborate this tells more about
what you know what's going on well what
they're trying to do is
influence every County
every County in Maryland has a a
committee of Republican leaders and they
are elected and if there's a a
replacement needed they're appointed and
it's approved by the governor they're
trying and they're very important in
County politics and they're pressuring
them to not provide any support that
means organizing
help for the campaign at the Grassroots
level and disincentivizing people from
doing that
as individuals too
and that could stack the deck now I
think the reaction is going to be in
places like Garrett and Allegheny County
in Washington County and others that are
basically conservative and Trump
territory it's going to it's going to
not it's not gonna work at all okay you
say that they're pressuring them what is
an example of that kind of pressure
withholding support
denying them access
they're not going to get the benefits of
being part of the the larger State
operations is that not blackmail
call it what you will there's it's
politics it is politics The
Establishment be it Republican or
Democrat are happy
to see the Republicans fail and lose if
it means populists people like Trump and
people who like Trump don't win
so what's the solution I don't know that
I I genuinely think you know do I think
that Lindsey Graham cares at all no he
high five he fist bumped Kamala Harris
he does not care he is a crony
establishment shill we did it Lindsay
yeah so is Kevin McCarthy so is Mitch
McConnell they're all terrible the
Republican party is despised by so many
people in this country and it's sad
because they're they're a good there are
more good Republicans than uh than good
Democrats but the Republican party is
just run by by pure corruption the two
Democrats are too don't get me wrong the
Chamber of Commerce Republican Elite
okay and I I call it the uniparty elite
because there's not that much difference
George Wallace once said there's not a
dime worth the difference between the
leadership of the Republican and
Democratic party that was back in 1968
or 72 something like that that's ancient
history for most people but that's what
was said and it's more true today than
back then okay the uniparty elite is
sold out to China
the Chamber of Commerce supports both of
them
leadership in Banks and Venture Capital
they give big money to Victory funds for
Republicans at the senior level they
give the same kind of money to the
Democrats
because it's all about the green for
them and you know Feathering their nest
yeah there's a I quoted I quote this
every now to get on the show but it's
called Woods's law from Tom Woods
whoever you vote for you end up getting
John McCain and it's true that in terms
of the actual party platforms yes the
parties are different I certainly don't
agree that they're identical but I
completely agree with you that at the
level of leadership they're pretty much
all in bed together thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there